Nobel laureates in physics and chemistry
laureates and economic sciences members
of the Academy ladies and gentlemen the
role of science is the question what is
regarded as the truth to uncover hidden
phenomena to see the possibilities which
are of skill to the ordinary mind the
passionate observer
equipped with imagination and creativity
leads us forward to a world with better
conditions we stand on the shoulders of
giants as Cyril ups new Giants appear
and show us the way forward some of them
are with us today's the progress of
mankind is very much connected to
materials the way natural materials can
be exploited and used and her new
man-made materials can be developed
materials have even given the names to
the ages of civilization the Stone Age
bronze iron silicon ages man is not able
to do anything with art materials it is
essential to understand the properties
and uncover the hidden secrets of
materials and unexpected states of
matter and to be able to design entirely
new and Italian structures constructed
using the smallest possible building
blocks today's intelligent man-made
materials would have been pure science
fiction just fifty years ago it is not
possible to plan for the unknown new
fundamental discoveries that may lead
applications which could not be foreseen
and the period between a fundamental
discovery and eventual applications is
often very long compared to the criteria
commonly used
by governments and funding agencies but
with the words taken from venerable the
American engineer and science
administrator as long as scientists are
free to pursue the truth wherever it may
lead there will be a flow of new
scientific knowledge to those who can
apply it to practical problems do you
live during the last century we have
witnessed an explosive growth of Science
and Technology a development nobody
could even dream on at the beginning of
the last century the French advocate of
Enlightenment jean-antoine the contorsi
he argued that the expanding knowledge
in the Natural Sciences would lead to
progressive development of human
capabilities and lead to a world of
individual freedom and moral compassion
since as he believed social evils are
the result of ignorance and error rather
than an inevitable consequence of the
human nature in this respect he seemed
to be too optimistic when it comes to
help humans treat each other we still
see corruption dishonesty and unethical
conduct in otherwise well developed
societies hiram new theoretical tools
for properly designed and formalized
negotiations help us to deal with
conflicting interests today science and
scientific knowledge are needed more
than ever we live in a time with
widespread resistance to knowledge for
even powerful world leaders deny
scientific knowledge a new term post
truth
has been added to the Oxford Dictionary
meaning her emotions affect people more
than facts we need to trust in science
because only knowledge can make the
world better Alfred Nobel
he recognized the importance of science
and those who uncover what has been
hidden who explained on mere existence
who improve the quality of our lives who
opened doors for future findings this
week is the big celebration of science
and today you are all welcome here to
listen to some of those who have
increased our knowledge and made a
difference to the way we think I will
now ask professor tools house Anson
member of the Nobel Committee for
physics to introduce the Nobel Prize in
Physics
[Applause]
so yeah good morning everybody so I'm
very happy for this opportunity to say a
few words about the Nobel Prize in
Physics 2016 and introduce the laureates
who are going to give 2016 Nobel
lectures in physics so here they are I'm
sure that many of you already know their
names it's David Paulus University of
Washington Seattle USA it's Duncan hold
a Princeton University also u.s.a and
it's Michael Kosta leads Brown
University United States so the citation
of the Academy that motivates the price
is for theoretical discoveries of
topological phase transitions and
topological phases of matter and I will
not make any attempt to explain what
that means to you yeah you will hear two
lectures later that will try to explain
to you what that means so I will instead
say just a few words about the low rates
so I start with Professor David Paulus
he was born in the UK 1934 he got his
PhD from Cornell University in the
United States and he's now the emeritus
professor at the University of
Washington Seattle and I should tell you
that Professor Paulus is a legendary
person among condensed matter physicists
so he has made really groundbreaking
contributions to theoretical physics I
will not take x from the lecture to list
all his achievements but I should
mention that although he's awarded this
year's Nobel Prize for his work on
topological states so
matter in topological phase transitions
many physicists my told the view that
his verdict when mesoscopic physics very
introduced the very central concept
without less energy might be as
important as the work that we are
celebrating today his achievement has
earned him many prestigious awards
including the Maxwell medal in price the
Wolf Prize for Physics the IOP Dirac
medal and a large on saw the price now I
already mentioned that they I've already
read the citation and as you can see it
has two pieces to it
topological phases of matter and
topological phase transitions these two
subjects are intellectually closely
connected but they are still distinct
and they are going to be presented in
two lectures by the two other laureates
and the first one will be given by
professor halt dein and i will now say a
few words about him so he was born in
London in 1951 got his PhD from
Cambridge University but ended up as the
Eugene Higgins professor of physics at
Princeton University where he is now
presently and still very very active and
he has worked in many areas of
theoretical physics again I won't give
any long list but I just mentioned that
in addition to the work that we are
honoring today
yes introduce the important concept in
physics the concept of loading a liquid
the concept of fractional exclusion
statistics and the concept of
entanglement spectrum and he has given
seminal contributions to the theory of
the quantum Hall effect
so now it's my pleasure to say also that
has been awarded the maxwell medal and
prize oliver Buckley condensed matter
prize the our CTP Dirac metal and now I
will call on professor Hall Dane to come
up and give mm first of the 2016 Nobel
lectures in physics please prepare to
hold a
thank you this is a challenging lecture
for me to give because usually I give
these talks to specialists but I'm going
to make an effort to give you some
flavor of three kind of surprising feet
surprising discoveries that both David
fellows who I'm going to talk for for a
bit and myself have made and these are
all things which I think were not
expected at all at the beginning of
whatever calculations were done to reach
these things and they will emerge your
surprises and I heard from Marcel din
ice about this David Sir work on this
thing which and it's again a similar
thing that they didn't understand
realize what good stuff was going to
happen until almost the end of the
calculations okay so I thought I'd give
a little bit of background before I do
because I'm not sure who I'm talking to
but of course you just recall high
school chemistry you've got orbitals
that get filled you have a set of energy
levels in atoms that quantum mechanics
[Music]
this makes discrete and you could get to
fill them up with electrons and the
usual case you can put two electrons in
each orbital because they have something
called spin which goes up and down and
I'm going to make an analogy for this
because this is actually what's going to
happen in the quantum Hall effect and
the simple case of the integer quantum
Hall effect we have a two dimensional
surface on which electrons can move with
a large magnetic field going normal to
the surface and in a magnetic field
electrons go around the little circles
just like in the atom but now it's the
magnetic force that drives you in a
circle the force at right angles to the
motion of the electron and in this case
it's as the radius of the orbit gets
bigger that corresponds to larger
kinetic energy of the electrons so in
that case we have
again a set of an energy level diagram
where we can fill up the orbitals but
instead of having a as in chemistry 1s
orbital or 2s and 2p and then 2d we
actually have a large number of orbitals
and in the quantum Hall effect the
integer quantum Hall effect the number
of orbitals is macroscopic is
proportional to the area of the system
the area in which the electrons are able
to move and there is one orbital one
independent orbital for every quantum of
magnetic flux that passes through the
area the system for that in case you
haven't seen any of this stuff before so
if I'm a strict density of electrons
let's choose because the number of the
number of orbitals in the in each of
these levels is degenerate levels is
proportional to the magnetic flux
density the magnetic fields we could
choose the magnetic fields just right so
we can completely fill up the lowest set
of orbitals here the lowest Lander level
we call these degenerate set of orbitals
lando levels and if I say if I take this
system where I just tuned things just
right so there's exactly the right
number of orbitals to be completely
filled by the electrons in the lowest
lambda level and the others are all
empty we get something that appears
initially to describe the integer
quantum Hall state that turns out to be
the earliest of the topological states
of matter that were experimentally found
and that was found by class 1 kissing in
1919 in 1981 and very quickly because of
implications it led to his Nobel Prize
in 85 so so when you have this situation
you you've got an energy gap if you're a
chemist you call it the homo-lumo gap or
something and and so this is a kind of
rigid system that the that that you
filled it just up to this level it's
going to cost you energy
to put any electrons and he in a higher
level and so if I try to squeeze the
system where I'm actually changing the
number area in which the electron is
allowed to move and therefore changing
them of orbitals if I compress this
thing down I will I will not be able to
compress it any further than having fill
this lando level up completely because
I'd have to if I pushed it together more
I'd have to put things in the next round
the level which cost me a lot more
energy so at first sight it looks that's
a very fine-tuned thing that you'd have
to get everything just right and the
special feature of the Hall effect that
from kletzing found is it's very robust
but actually this is a topological
system and because something has to
happen at the edge you don't actually
need to fine-tune anything to get this
just right because at the edge of the
system if I think about the electrons
going around in little whatever yeah if
they go around in little circles I've
drawn them going around in clockwise
circles here but if they actually reach
the edge of the system and try to go
around in a clockwise circle they go
bang and they will they will bounce back
off the wall so in the one the sort of
the orbits that hit the wall will
actually precess around the wall in the
anti-clockwise direction and that's one
of the hallmarks of topological systems
they have strange States at the edge of
the system and this is what we call the
the edge States there
counter-propagating edge states that
have a throttle feature that they only
allow propagation around the edge in a
single direction not turned and of
course that's because if they can only
go one way it means if I looked at this
thing backwards in time they'd be going
the other way and this is a system with
what we call broken time reversal
invariance the magnetic field breaks the
symmetry of systems under the change of
the direction of time so the orbitals at
the edge actually go up a little bit and
therefore there's a place as a reservoir
of electrons at the edge the Fermi level
is the highest occupied state the
chemical potential and as I change the
magnetic field I will just be I will be
changing the
they read how much I fill this thing up
at the edge but I will still maintain
the gap in the bulk of the system so
this system does have gapless
excitations at the edge there's a no gap
which is very small it's proportional to
the length of the one over the length of
the edge so it's a microscope
microscopic gap at the edge of the
system but I still have in the interior
this large bulk gap which is a
topologically protected State well what
fun cliff singh found he did these
measurements of you measured the whole
resistance a whole resistivity but i'm
going to talk about the whole
conductance which is one over that so
what he sees in the picture you you
change the magnetic field and the whole
conductance
sticks at various values which turned
out to be quantized and it turns out to
be an integer times your fundamental
constants a squared over H or a squared
over 2 pi H bar and being an integer is
what finally got understood to be a
topological property
topology we heard from Hans Hansen that
the when the prices were announced about
your counting number of holes in in
bagels and things and those can't be
other than integers these are
topological properties that we'll see
and this is actually what a very nice
result of Davidson's means okay so the
Vonk listing system is much dirtier than
the theoretical toy model I presented to
you it's got all kinds of details of
junk inside it and the work at the early
80s focused on these difficult problems
of how you treat this order and and
randomness and what was going on and but
there were kind of tell you about that
of Davis is he had the idea to study not
the effect of this kind of random dirty
system which is difficult but a
different Lister a simple periodic
system a kind of addict on a crystalline
background of his choosing to the to
these Landau levels and Marcel denies
who worked them they said at the end of
the day that was David's brilliance and
the thing that he actually chose a
tractable problem as opposed to sticking
around that the physically relevant
problem was apparently the disordered
one and we have this sort of situation
the the ideal case where it's clean in
the middle is perfectly flat and this is
a case where Bob Laughlin who won the
prize little--it later for the
fractional quantum Hall effect had
earlier given an extremely powerful
argument that says if I have this flat
system in the bulk and the only places
where there's energy levels at the Fermi
level or at the edges then a few applied
this electric field that to make things
flow the charge would flow across the
system within a way that couldn't be
affected by any kind of dirt because he
it was too far for any scattering
between points at one Fermi energy and
the other Fermi energy and so here that
there was a very clear argument that
related a gap in the bulk region of a
sample to this perfect conductor perfect
quantization of the hall conductance
where it's just given by a whole number
times from the mental constants so the
actual problem that that people trying
to be practical or trying to be
realistic would have tried to solve is
this one here where there's a lot of
junk in the middle and a dirty potential
but as I said this is very difficult and
what David took some very beautiful
results from Hofstadter and solve this
problem here which should be a perfectly
periodic wave in the in the middle the
potentials periodic which means some
points the the the lowest state in the
system will be down here and the highest
state will be at this point so the lambo
level which in this case is a perfectly
flat infinitesimally thin energy level
gets smeared out into a range of
energies between the top and bottom of
this periodic potential and that's this
so-called TK n n paper the Fallas kimoto
and nightingale and Denise I guess some
people trying to be cute put TK and and
squared like that but the other three
were three postdoctoral collaborators
kimoto was Davis postdoc and nightingale
and denies where other people's postdoc
I guess at Washington University of
Washington Seattle
anyway they they they together with
David they
look to this problem of what the
presence of this simple periodic
potential added to the Lando levels
would do to the integer quantum Hall
effect and the Soraa the bottom line is
they discovered a remarkable formula
that they hadn't been looking for and
that according to Marcel denies it
jumped out of him only at the the very
end of the calculation okay they were
too concerned with the details but at
the end they suddenly saw something
something was important so David had
been particularly interested in a very
and it's very interesting toy model all
the people kind of fascinated with at a
time it's called it often goes by the
name of the Hofstadter butterfly because
you had extremely beautiful pattern come
out and and Douglas Hofstadter found
this in the 1970s and he loved desire
aesthetic appeal I guess it's a model of
a crystal in a magnetic field and people
have gone to town on this model because
it's got all kinds of beautiful features
in it but basically it's just the same
model as before kinetic energy of
particles in a magnetic field and then
of just a simplest possible periodic
potential a cosine potential in the
x-direction and a cosine potential in
the y-direction added together and this
thing is called the butterfly it's
usually shown rotate his sideways and I
guess it's got tremendous amount of fine
structure and fractal structures
floating around in it but that's not
what sintering interesting us here today
it has these very narrow levels which I
guess for the purposes of calculating
the whole conductivity this was done by
Yosi Avron and his former student they -
they donated this picture to me so
there's no copyright concerns in my
lectures and so the numbers here tell
you what this integer the should be here
at the bottom this thing is not the
lander levels but it's very close to the
Landau levels structure is for it's
almost identical to what you would see
for a simple Landau level structure and
you've got a lot of a very narrow levels
and you fill the first one you get one
filled level a second one - but when you
look in this other structure you get all
kinds of other weird numbers floating
around and they got fascinated the team
got a fascinating thing first of all how
can you calculate these numbers these
integers what
are they and and so the basic point that
Marcel tells me that David pointed out
was that Lofton's argument tells you if
you've got a gap in the bulk of the
system you've got to get this integer
quantization coming out and he that lost
in a done it for the simple Lando level
case but this thing also has gaps in the
bulk and if they're coming chemical
potentials in there you should get
quantization and they were struggling to
find what was the formula that get these
integers and so the after they solve
lots of equations and found the thing
they realized they were found how to
calculate these integers they found
there was had to be a more general
principle than just solving what were
called daya fans are equations some
mathematical structures and basically if
you take you have a periodic potential
it's actually not the usual kind of the
crystal because there's some the
periodic the the the unit cell you have
to use is not the simple one of the of
the cosine potential it's related to how
many how many of the unit cells contain
an integer number of magnetic flux coins
here so it's a rather strange band
structure but basically if you've got
something periodic there's a block
theorem that says you can write the wave
function of a I can state of a system in
a periodic potential as two things a
periodic function times an exponential e
to the ir e to the ikx or KL and the
details are what's going on in the bands
are all contained in this periodic thing
so they took a very standard formula a
fundamental formula for the conducting
calculating the conductivity of a system
called the Kubo formula and plug this
stuff in so the Cooper formula is
usually used for calculating the
dissipative part of the resistance
but in the case where you're looking
this hall is it hole resistance where
you're looking at the response to an
electric field which is parallel which
is at right angles to the motion of the
current so it doesn't dissipate any
energy you get different formulas well
they put this in and they crank the
handle and they eventually got a very
nice formula they don't actually comment
on it in the paper that how nice this
was in some sense but they ended up with
a formula that depended
on the details of the band structure we
sure can't of the wave functions of the
band structure which are contained in
this function here there's no reference
anymore to the energy levels of the
problem the energy levels are there in
the kuba formula but after integrating
stuff out and using formulas for the
velocity of the system you find the
energy levels in when you're calculating
this whole conductance this one which is
dissipative if not the usual ohmic law
conductance the energy levels all drop
out so this is the first form they got
of a formula for and after they will
I'll show you in a minute how this turns
into an integer but they found this this
formula which gave you the hall
conductance which is these numbers a
squared over H which is one click sings
number of twenty twenty twenty
twenty-five thousand three hundred and
ten ohms I guess ohms to the minus one
sorry and then we have this knot these
numbers here which you can do some
simple mathematics with Stokes's theorem
on so they found this formula and
shortly after they published their paper
another another another very influential
discovery in in mathematics in physics
comb was that Michael burry discovered
that the adiabatic approach to quantum
mechanics had missed out an important
geometrical phase and in fact this is
another piece of work that people a lot
of people think should get the Nobel
Prize this is my hint to the committee
but it's geometric so I guess you could
say it shouldn't have come this year
anyway that self so a very simple was a
spin in a spin which was polarized along
the along some axis and you gradually
rotate this and you find that you pick
up this additional phase which is very
geometrical it's actually the solid
angle the spin times e to the I II can
spin times a solid angle enclosed by the
path which is ambiguous modulo four PI
and therefore the spin has to be an
integer or a half integer which we knew
for other reasons but these are typical
of these topological things that have
interesting consequences this tells you
that spin
has to be quantized for example even if
you didn't do it by algebra so anyway
the mathematician mathematical physicist
Barry Simon in 1983 just after the two
papers have been published
I guess he he he recounts that someone
else tipped him off about this
connection and he should look at it or
two there had to be a connection and he
found that the two things matched
together very well that they the thallus
the T KNN expression was an integral
over a curvature associated with the
phase of Barry's Sahana me and
mathematically it was an integral over a
compact manifold which turned out to be
the Brillouin zone which is
topologically equal to a torus and in
fact he pointed out this connection to
what is really a mathematical extension
of Gauss's famous theorem I agree diem
why should I guess he he discovered
while he was a foreign member of the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
because he was joined in 1821 and this
is 28th and he thought I think cows gas
seems to have thought this was the most
most amazing discovery he ever made in
mathematics it
so what Miguel's discovered was what we
heard from Ventura hands hanson about
the bagels and the thing so gas discover
something that you of probably you can
you can easily get the simplest version
of it for your from your high school
algebra class right you know that the
the surface area of a sphere is 4 PI R
squared whereas her radius and the
Gaussian curvature that Gauss introduced
of course for the sphere is is uniform
and it's 1 over R squared so if I
integrate the gaussian curvature over
the surface area of the sphere i get 4
pi
but what gauss discovered as this
amazing theorem was that i can change
the shape of the sphere to anything else
like a football or a banana or whatever
and they still got 4 pi and this is
called the gas when a cat the theorem I
guess because cows never wrote it up
properly and when they put all the
details in later so if I take this thing
we get this service by now famous
account of the Swedish in the German
pretzels but and we also get the account
that the famous relation between coffee
cups and bagels you have a mug is the
same as a ball what's being called a
Loving Cup is the same as a Swedish
pretzel and I'm not quite sure what kind
of Loving Cup this is because it's got
three handles but that's the same as a
German press although some kind I
thought well I'm not sure if that's
something like nationality kind of
combination but anyway so this is the
list apology that you see every year
when people giving give talks about
topological insulators they love the
coffee cup I'd like to see actually the
Swedish pretzel changing into the Loving
Cup and backwards rather be a change
from the coffee cup in the bagel so okay
what they what the the formula that they
found that that berry simon pointed out
that this formula was really the the
churn the first churned class integral
well basically can divide into two parts
it's two things that see the it's the
integral of a curvature which you can
write as an anti-symmetric tensor but
now in momentum space not in real space
or case base block space and then this
is the formula the other part of the
formula is the formula for the the berry
curvature and in fact it's kind of
interesting fact that again talking
about things which had discovered before
their time this this formula is in a
very correct paper or something like
this formula a 3d version which is non
topological is in a 1954 paper by car
plus and not injure that was denounced
as completely wrong and nonsense for
many many years
only in 1999 was it recognized that it
was actually a case of very curvature
and somewhat later they was shown to be
essentially correct in a lot of
situations it being applied to so this
again topology takes a formulas and not
obvious until some so I guess Barry
Simon did a very big contribution in in
pointing out the mathematical framework
of what
David and the other collaborators had
found so just quickly in these formulas
if we write them down this people make a
big correspondence now to think of
things like something like
electromagnetic fields in in momentum
space because the the curvature is kind
of like the magnetic fields and the
curvature can be written there's
something like the curl of a vector
potential domain if so which is called a
barre connection and the Barry's phase
is the integral of the Barre connection
around the closed path and it's very
much like the bow Maharana phase when
you take a electron around the loop and
in the presence of a magnetic field and
try to calculate what phase it picks up
when it goes around that loop and the
barre face because the Barre phase is e
to the I something this is a number
which is only defined modulo 2 pi from
this you quite quickly see the
mathematics of Stokes theorem tells you
that the integral of the curvature over
the over something bounded by the by a
curve has to be 2 pi has to be 2 pi
times an integer so this was the form
that that fellows found the actual form
they wrote in their paper looked
something like this
they'd integrated by parts C the first
formula and then they found but this
thing has to be is when you do the
mathematics is it's obviously an integer
times e squared over H and that was the
thing so that in fact as I said Marcel
the nice told me that this were only
emerged at the very end of the
calculation of kind of afterthought he
has some talk about the they realized
there was an elephant in the room after
looking at their form that had to be
something a lot more in their paper that
than just the actual values of these
numbers in this nice colorful diagram
right the numbers of course were not
interesting really I mean the only
challenge is that you can compute them
but then the big picture rather than
working rather than being interested in
Hopf status by the fly the big picture
is to come out with a very fundamental
formula that no one had expected existed
before and this is this amazing work
that he did okay so this is so out of
this my own work which was also nation
a bit later comes from seeing that this
integer quantum Hall effect can actually
occur without Lando levels so maybe you
could say this was implicit in the Tico
name result but I don't know it wasn't
noticed the 1982 paper was all about the
periodic potential on nando levels and
it hadn't really been appreciated that
if it's a topological thing in the
details surely can't matter and the
pacific realization in terms of Lando
levels is very complicated and not very
practical for for hopefully finding new
materials right and so I was again
stumbled over this feature that you
could actually write down a very simple
model that turned out to be very
influential because you can't do very
simple calculations with it it turned
out to be something like graphene it's a
modified form of graphene where you our
second neighbor electrons can tunnel
between second neighbors and they pick
up a little bit of a complex phase which
is a time reversal breaking effect as
they up around so you end up with an
extremely simple kind of so-called tight
binding band structure and it turns out
to have it turns out to really to be the
first of the topological insulators this
is not a this is a time reversal broken
topological insulator which in my view
actually has more potential practic
practical potential than the normal kind
that people are studying a lot now but
we'll see what happens with this so this
was actually grat it's kind of graphene
at the time I we didn't know that
someone would invent graphene by taking
a scotch tape and on pencil scraping a
pencil over something and doing scotch
tape so I put in my paper that this
would be a single mono layer of graphite
but it would be inconceivable for
someone to actually realize that and of
course I think the lesson is that
material science can take us to play but
if it can be done someone will do it
right however crazy the as long as it's
not real black holes and something like
that so whatever the crazy thing model
you come up with if it's just something
interesting it's most likely someone
will be able to make something that does
it whether it's cold atoms or they
otherwise so one of the features of
these
is that they have they have this one-way
channel around the boundary where things
move in one direction in the in the
first in the Lando level case that that
was really coming from the direction of
the magnetic field but in graphene if
you look at it graphene ickle an edge of
graphene there's various edges and
there's a nice one called the zigzag
edge mode and you find that graphene has
itself for the edge if I take a view
along the edge there's actually a bound
state which comes between two different
Dirac points in graphene and exists in
part of the surface Brewin zone and it
connects see things once you you can
open up a gap in graphene by turning it
from a semi metal to a semiconductor in
two ways by breaking inversion symmetry
or breaking time reversal symmetry when
you break inversion symmetry you get
something boring the these this this
state has to be attached to either the
top or the bottom band in the boring
cases both ends of the state to attach
to either the valence band or the
conduction band but in the interesting
case one in one point ends up can touch
the conduction band the other to the
valence band and there's a kind of
channel a plumbing connection between
the two that you can drive States up and
down by putting a magnetic field through
this flake of graphene like substance
and if I fill the system up to the Fermi
level is in the gap I find I have these
one-way these things that travel one-way
this is actually the hallmark of the of
the topological states they typically
have something very interesting at the
boundary and the start of all about to
about ten years ago or twelve years ago
Eugene and Malayan and Charlie Kane
there's something which I'd actually
thought of doing and I never did the
calculation I thought it obviously won't
work they took two copies of my model
white and put them on top of each other
one with up spin electrons going one way
and the bouncing electrons going around
the edge the other way and I'd have
thought that this would these things
would mix and scatter but there was a
new a new topological invariant which
was something like minus 1 for the churn
number that was hadn't been appreciated
before so this this was an extra
topological invariant not the one that
Barry Simon had pointed out with what
there's
tkn and formula was and that has led
suddenly to generalizations for three
dimensions and people discovering lots
of very interesting topological
materials lying in the Bertie shells
okay so there was a this toy model which
he says somehow a relation to the TK and
n story again has a has a very fruitful
history it's also been translated into
photonics and there's a feel now of
topological photonics where you get
right to travel one way around the
boundary of things okay so the third
thing if I have time I'll talk about how
much time do I have
okay okay is the the magnetic chains
which also is about the same time about
probably within a month a few months of
the of the of the of the quantum hall
measurements by eclipsing well that this
time things are coming out and and this
was actually been being baptized by
Shogun when who made who recently made a
very exhaustive classification using
very fancy mathematics of Ko board ism
or Co homology or something to classify
all possible subsets of topological
things and this time the Sun sense is
the hydrogen atom of topological
materials it turns out of course I did
not know that at the time when I found
it but it was something totally
unexpected and of course that's the
hallmark of topological material say
they they differ fundamentally by some
number being one or two as opposed to
zero which gives them a property that's
not present in normal matter and this
stuff behaves very differently from what
was expected to happen okay so actually
this was a interesting case I actually
was unable to publish it at the time
because these two journals struck
dismiss this out of hand based on
referee saying you know it's a manifest
contradiction two fundamental principles
of physics a bit like what happened to
car plus and nothing sure that I
mentioned and by the time it was
published there was actually a more
sophisticated argument that that
actually removed
what I realized had been the connection
to the earlier work that we're going to
hear next from coastal it's
costless phallus transition because
there's a very nice mapping from
two-dimensional classical systems at
finite temperature where there's a
Boltzmann factor describing a
probability weight to quantum mechanics
in one space and one time dimension
where the Boltzmann factor gets replaced
by an amplitude and the quantum
mechanics is richer than classical
mechanics because Boltzmann factors are
always positive while in this case there
may be some time reversal invariance but
the amplitude can either be positive or
negative any interference effects
between one path having a positive
amplitude they all have a negative
amplitude and therefore the two things
can actually cancel some process
completely so the thing was in this
paper I see that so this my my lost
preprint because I didn't have any
records of it it was just cited in
people's work at the time but GNO sure
you had I found had finally kept a copy
of it and in fact it's kind of
interesting to read it again and it's
actually basically using the Khosla
Fairless argument translated the quantum
mechanics to say why the conventional
wisdom of the time was was incorrect you
can find it on the archive if you want
now I posted it so in magnetic chains we
have ferromagnets where the light they
like to line up or antiferromagnets
where they opposite the case and this
might work dealt with a anti
ferromagnetic in one dimension okay and
the feature there is what was known at
the time is that though antiferromagnet
the ferromagnets got a conserved angular
momentum conserved its total spin so
it's kind of stable ground state but the
antiferromagnet the quantum fluctuations
in one dimension destroy long-range
order so people knew that as a
mathematical theorem that they sort of
but they had a remarkable thing there
was a exact solution of this magnetic
problem for spin 1/2 system by Hans
bethe who incidentally was David's
thesis advisor at Cornell and before he
went off to tell us how the Sun produces
energy he was interested in quantum
chains and he did a remarkable piece of
work through significance I'm sure he
didn't understand because he lucked onto
a solution of this model that seemed to
work and
took about 50 years to discover why it
had worked and bata cleared and
understand why because he his paper says
my next paper will do it in two
dimensions and three dimensions but of
course that never happened because this
is a very specifically one-dimensional
thing but in the this was a very obscure
difficult piece of work and no one knew
how to calculate anything else except
energy levels from it but in the
mid-1970s another piece of work a
remarkable piece of work going back to
the 30s a Jordan ring the transformation
which Maps spins which are bosons bosons
really two fermions by relating relating
up spin up to be filled and spin down to
be empty states gave a way to translate
these spin chain languages into into
fermion language and this actually was a
lot easier to do calculations with than
the beta and SATs and it was it allowed
one to translate things into
calculations you could do and I guess
progress always happens when you can
actually turn something into some
calculation can actually do on the on a
piece of paper or understand then you
can understand all the details and this
was done by Luther and Peschel Luther
was at nor DJ for a long time after that
and they turned this thing into a
fermion problem and to cut a long story
short they got most of it right but they
missed out some detail which I
discovered later by applying what this
lot and your liquid theory that was
mentioned and I found that the loot that
they didn't really have an understanding
of what happened when you went for a
easy access to an easy plain easy plane
to easy access antiferromagnet whether
the spins when the plane are wanting the
point out of the plane and looking at
the numerical this this new tool gave us
a thing to extract numbers from the beta
answers calculation they showed
immediately some term was missing and
these pictures here actually exactly the
quantum translation of the cosmos Palace
story that Michael will tell Michael
tell you about so it turned out that the
spin 1/2 system was was special rather
than the spin one that one system they
both were costly at Silas transition
we're driving you for an easy plane to
easy access but there was a special
cancellation effect which I guess will
vaguely say here between the within the
spin half case here that you've two
isolated what Mike's going to tell you
about from a two dimensional space to a
spacetime diagram and here there's a
tunneling process that takes you between
a configuration whether these are
compass needles in the plane they kind
of say in the plane and as you go around
this periodic boundary conditions you go
around in the first case there's no kind
of winding number the second case
there's a twist on it like a mobius
strip or sand your twist went in and you
can't get from those two things
continuously you have to do some kind of
breakdown and there's a telling point
which is a vortex and it turns out that
for the spin half case you only got a
double vortex because if you do it you
have to do this process of tunneling on
one of the bonds between the spins and
if you took it you look at the process
on two neighboring bonds they should
everything should be identical if the
bonds were identical strengths except
the two pars one in one passes one of
the spins rotated 180 degrees clockwise
and the other one it rotated 180 degrees
anti-clockwise wishes so the difference
of the past is rotating a single spin
360 degrees but if it's a half integer
spin you get a minus one factor so the
quantum mechanics told you something so
I'm looking at this way gave you a
completely new way to look at things and
it turned out that the conventional
wisdom was completely wrong and and
finally so we came up with this new
story which shocked people at the time
because it it conflicted with
preconceived notions based on on the
beta answers equation seem to seem to
confirm incorrect ideas about spin ways
and finally it's not go through this too
much but at the end of the day this
turned out this this new state with this
gapped integers integer spin liquid
state that I found turned out to be one
of the simplest topological states with
a very non-trivial entanglement there's
spin one system and the interesting
thing is a spin one can be viewed as two
spin has
together and in the usual case they just
point in some direction but here they
the spin won against the fact
rationalizing the two spinner house
which one on either side and they grab
hand they grab hunt they grab on to the
spin one half from the others from their
partner and the other so next next went
along and get entangled into a singlet
state and when you do that you get left
the two to the two spins at the end of
the chain they let left they get left
with one arm up stretched out here and
the other arm up stretched out here so
they're like two half spins at the end
this is two unexpected spin one heart at
the end of the thing and this is
precisely the analog of had the edge
States in the quantum Hall state again
this this feature you find in all the
topological states that there's
something strange happening at the
boundary where the edges are where
things that go from something to normal
so anyway so that brings me to the
basically the end of the story I had to
I couldn't really give you all the
technical details and it's probably
quite confusing because it's very
difficult to explain this to a general
audience even a general audience of
scientists if they're not condensed
matter physicists and but basically the
why this I my opinion why my
interpretation of why this prize was
awarded now is because so much as
suddenly in the last 10 years have come
out of all this old stuff this these
these various little findings which in
each turn came from people finding
something more amazing than they were
looking for just something noticed
something strange and it was calm it
gave you a new way of looking at things
and what's happened is that we've read
over the life Tovar over my lifetime in
in in condensed matter physics I've seen
that the the kind of things we were
taught and learned from textbooks like
actually off the mermaid and things back
in the 70s a lot of the details that
were thought to be really important then
and really we put them away as boring
boring stuff which doesn't relate not
important and all kinds of new new
things like entanglement and new ideas
which were not present in any of his old
stuff have turned have become the
central kind of questions that we're
struggling with and you know this after
they after the topological materials
started to be found
concretely as real things there was also
proposals that
they could be used as a so-called
platform for topological quantum
information processing and that of
course has stimulated a large amount of
interest and there's been a huge amount
of people and cold atoms quantum
information condensed matter even the
string theorist ed ed Witten is now the
voting part of its time I guess string
theory is you know there's this some
spare time to deal with other things now
and getting very interested in in
extending all this topology to four
dimensions so we're now doing
we now have tables of topological matter
up to eight dimensions so now you can
see how the influence for an outside the
field has influenced things but it's a
very exciting area because we're finding
all kinds of well I consider neat stuff
about quantum mechanics that we didn't
know before and there seems to be plenty
of new insights to gain so so that when
you can find something very simple and
beautiful we all think that's the way
that's the truth and maybe we're going
to learn a lot about matter and learn a
lot about possibly applications of it
thank you
[Applause]